konzentrationslager buchenwald
280.000 menschen waren hier inhaftiert
juden senkt die roma chronisten
sogenannte asoziale homosexuelle sogar
kinder 56.000 kamen hier ums leben
heute ist buchenwald friedhof
gedenkstätte und ortiz erinnern
im ehemaligen bekleidungs magazin ist
die ausstellung zur geschichte des
lagers neu eingerichtet worden
mehr aufmerksamkeit erhalten nun fragen
nach der entstehung des
nationalsozialismus und nach der
akzeptanz in der gesellschaft
daneben dokumentiert die ausstellung die
wirklichkeit im lager fotos text
dokumente videos und hörstationen geben
einblicke in den alltäglichen schrecken
als haftgrund vermerkte es in den
unterlagen
ausländer freundlichkeit auch viele
objekte sind in der ausstellung zu sehen
sind so alltägliche gestand und ich
glaub dir immer das passiert hat es mir
jederzeit passieren
eine überraschend zurückhaltend der
ausstellung schreckliche bilder gibt es
nur wenige der grundton ist leise keine
fotos von leichen bergen
stattdessen der wagen mit dem die
leichen transportiert wurden
das ziel ist es die besucher tatsächlich
auch wieder lage ist in die zelte und
ich sage jetzt mal ein bild vor gewalt
platz fast schön wirken diese
häftlingskleidung frisch gewaschen und
da dreht kapiert spärlich die hinweise
auf das grauen braucht es nicht
schlimmere bilder und gegen das
vergessen zu bestehen weinen bildet
nicht damit man etwas aus dieser
geschichte lernt damit man damit umgehen
kann
damit wir das umsetzen kann für die
eigene verantwortung brauchen sie mehr
da müssen sie über das warnen
hinausgehen und müssen frage stellen
können müssen diskutieren müssen den ort
sozusagen zu einer permanenten konferenz
umgestaltet wo gesellschaftliche gruppen
miteinander diskutieren wie eine bessere
gesellschaft aufgebaut werden kann wenn
sie bei der emotionalität bleiben und
dort verzweifelt die beeindrucken
versuchen hervorzurufen
dann schicken sie diese ort in die
bedeutungslosigkeit szenenwechsel
berlin wir haben die architekten holzer
und kobler neben zürich ihren zweiten
standort der büroleiter berichtet
barbara holzer vom neuesten stand des
white city center einem
informationszentrum zu einer wichtigen
epoche von tel avivs
architekturgeschichte
als white city weiße stadt wird eine
ansammlung von über 4.000 gebäuden
bezeichnet die alle im bauhaus stil
errichtet wurden die meisten entstanden
in den 30er und 40er jahren viele von
deutschen immigranten gebaut
seit 2003 gehört die weiße stadt zum
unesco welterbe
diese lose ansammlung von gebäuden durch
ein zentrum zu einem großen ganzen
werden exemplarisch seien für des
gesamten staates sollte die stadt
widerspiegeln die art von architektur
und daher ist dieses zentrum hatten wir
das gefühl immer musste ich im grunde
genommen die stadt in das haus
hereinholen
es entsteht so ein offener ort der
begegnung der information und der
erforschung von tel avivs bau aus
geschichte und als besonderer akzent
schwebt über der dachterrasse ein 15
meter ballon in dem sich das bauhaus
erbe der stadt widerspiegelt geplant ist
der kugel spiegel temporären für die
nächsten zwei jahre bis zur eröffnung
des hauses
schade eigentlich es ist egal ob groß
und laut oder kleinen gleise für jeden
ort des gedenkens muss ich die form
finden in der meisten kraft und
überzeugung liegt